oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh my god
right now I'm in San Jose on a big
summer work trip and I've got ten days
to get to Moab Utah and then back down
to LA with this much distance and that
little time I was gonna fly but then
someone I know said you should take this
Tesla they said to make sure you haven't
driven in eight years but you've also
never driven the Tesla I couldn't say no
it's time for a road trip oh so cool
that is never gonna get old oh my god I
can't believe this I am so nervous
and so excited right now I have no words
for this like I can't even explain
anything I just have to get started and
we're just we're just gonna go that's
what's gonna happen here
wah can help future great here editing
this video now passphrase very excited
but what he doesn't know is he's going
to make this trip way harder for himself
an EP and he's also going to make some
of the dumbest most dangerous decisions
he's ever made in his adult life but he
doesn't know that now you know that back
to the excitement wah can help this is
the first moment in my life when I'm in
a self-driving car with self-driving
moment it's the first turn and it's
doing it
obviously it should but it's still going
for leaving to know
oh god it's amazing whoo man huh all
right
all right oh my god this was really
overwhelming and I've spent all my
adrenaline I need to calm down and eat a
sandwich I haven't done any significant
driving for nearly a decade on the last
road trip that I took it ended in a
pretty bad accident everyone walked away
but after that I just didn't want to
drive so I hardly ever did it which
meant I was a nervous wreck every time I
did which made me drive even less and
then because I live in a big city I
didn't need to drive but I'm gonna use
this opportunity to start again I'm
nervous
but so far the Tesla's made it a lot
easier for me and boy have I missed
driving just coming back from the store
and oh my god is it beautiful blues not
my color but that car looks fantastic
now that I've done the first leg on the
highway what is it car now that I've
done the first leg and I haven't died
it's fantastic it's an amazing car but
now I'm gonna spend a little bit in a
more focused frame of mind playing
around with like all of the settings on
the screen and figuring out a few things
before I continue onward with the next
leg of this Drive
this has been a real moment in my life
and just a fantastic driving experience
but I noticed that the click and the
animation of the click of the car are
not synchronized so one star literally
unusable I've made it to the first
supercharger location with 45 miles left
on the battery which is way closer than
I would ever cut it with a gas tank I
have some real range anxiety with cars
but I thought I would just trust the map
and what it's telling me and so here I
am waiting on line for the next
supercharger slot that's available okay
so pulling in 104 103 kilowatts which is
crazy and I need to leave it here for
about 40 minutes before I continue on
the next leg of the trip just perfect
because this is in a little mall area
and I've got some errands I need to run
get back from errands and there's a
hat-trick of exits it looks like we're
pretty set to continue on the road oh my
god I can't believe how exciting this is
forgot about this turns out the car
won't let you drive if you're still
plugged in so I'm guessing stop charging
this car is goddamn magic all right calm
down calm down it's very exciting calm
down oh yeah the door closes when I sit
okay okay let's do this
[Music]
one of the great things about doing a
road trip in America is all of these
little rest stops that exist where you
can just pull over and take a break go
to the bathroom maybe get a snack it's
really nice oh and by the way
beware of snakes every vessel needs a
name and she seems like a Bailey to you
Bailey blue I look forward to our trip
together
[Applause]
[Music]
so holy dead it's snowing we're up high
enough that it's there's snow on the
ground
this is unbelievable like I'm not sure
it looks up the way on the camera but
holy hell is the visibility low it's
like it is a gas station in the corner I
feel like I'm in the mist look at this
it's amazing so I'm totally unprepared
for this weather this hoodie is very
warm but it's not snow warm but I'm
taking a little break here because the
visibility was just zero on the freeway
and it never snows in London and I like
I've gone all here without seeing any
snow and I'm just so excited right now
and happy and very cold and I just
wanted to walk over and see what this
little thing was in the snow Oh
beautiful beautiful snow leave those
trucks in the snow in the forest in the
background it's just beautiful okay it
is beautiful but I'm also breathing
okay I've realized it's actually gonna
get pretty dark soon and I'm at the I'm
at like 5,000 feet I think the only way
out of this is through the snow and I
want to do it before it gets dark
so I'm gonna load up on some rest stop
coffee and then we're gonna get going
you're all strapped in the back seat
stay cozy we've got some serious snow to
drive through
[Music]
I didn't realize that the road I was
driving over is the Donner Pass I feel
like the luckiest man alive right now I
bumped into a guy who's flying a drone
and now I really feel like I need a
drone I don't need a drone well this has
been quite the first day back at driving
in any other car I would have been
terrified through that Thank You Bailey
blue
well that was king amazing all right I
was planning to go farther today but the
snow in the Donner Pass that took a
while and it took a lot out of me so I'm
gonna do the smart thing and I'm not
gonna push further I'm gonna get there
we go
I'm going to get a hotel in the local
area instead of being a crazy person and
pushing on to Reno nears hotel is
apparently like a cabin in the woods
very Christmassy feels appropriate this
was a good decision
the instant I stopped driving I realized
I'm tireder and I thought I was very
glad to be getting into a room to be
able to spend the night and relax
whoo-hoo desk all right time to set up
workstation and pull all the footage off
those cards and see what I was actually
able to keep in the end I love the snow
I love the pool
speaking of cold okay so last night I
wanted to test the thing if there's a
way to charge the Tesla from just
regular on regular electrical outlets
which I spotted on the outside of the
hotel I set up last night so it didn't
look too promising last night I just
want to see this morning how is it done
oh it's charging at 3 miles per hour
we've added 22 miles overnight this is
really good because this means I can
possibly try something that I was
thinking about last night
now to get to Moab here's what I should
do I should take Interstate 80 up to
Salt Lake City that's the smart route
it's filled with these superchargers if
you're driving a Tesla really long way
these things charge it up really fast
the only thing is I've already driven
across this road so I have an idea for a
different route a more interesting ride
that I've never done is this way across
what's known as the loneliest Road in
America for good reason there's nothing
out there including superchargers this
distance is way too long for a Tesla to
do on a single charge but I've
discovered these things RV parks it'll
charge a lot slower than a supercharger
but it'll work
there's an RV park here at Fox peak
station and there's an RV park here at
Eli this distance is 283 miles and a
Tesla's maximum range is 300 miles and I
get stranded along this road it's gonna
be a real problem so in order to make
this work Fox peak equals 100% charge I
cannot leave Fox peak with less than a
completely full battery otherwise I
might not make it and there is nothing
out here so that's the plan at 6:30 in
the morning I'm happy to have woken up
and get started early because today
might be the longest day of driving
but of course before we can get started
navigate to the nearest Starbucks
there's nothing cozier than being in a
snowy world in a warm car on your way to
get some coffee
sounds like a coffee emergency whatever
that was I was talking to the barista at
Starbucks and she said that this kind of
snow in June is something she's only
seen four times in the 20 years she's
lived here so I was feeling like the
luckiest man alive yesterday and now I
feel just twice as lucky that I get to
see this
rina hole on the horizon oh it's still
pretty cold out here all right let's go
inside this casino
well I sure hope I don't miss what's on
this channel
whoo
it's a buffet reimagined
hi I'm going to need to walk with bacon
egg and cheese I don't know why I said
egg of course does that get it yeah the
bacon of cheese yeah two please I'm not
really two people though am I second
coffee acquired because we all know the
first coffee is a warm-up and now we're
on to Fallon
this place is the tests where we find
out if I can do the route I want or not
Oh Fox peak not pizza at Fox peak
station this is the moment of truth
let's see what we have here thinking
that this part doesn't go into that part
I have no other adapters that can bridge
the gap thing has the same thing so what
I need to do yes leave my credit card
for like the 70th time authorizing
authorizing Hey
all right oh my god it's a miracle oh
it's gonna take a long time sitting here
with the Tesla getting a charge for the
next leg of the journey it's a little
pooped I'm a little pooped
I'm also bit coffee doubt so I'm going
to get some of my little placement
Coffee pills which are nice and have
some vats and then I think I'll show you
while I waits a couple of the features
of this Tesla
all right the number one thing I worried
about before driving the Tesla was this
a ginormous screen and how distracting
it would be I mean it is huge but it
handles really well so when you when you
get the navigation right so I'm gonna
navigate I want to get to Eli
Nevada what it'll do and it would fill
in if we had any kind of internet
connection it'll show an overview of
your route if you want or it'll show a
particular leg like to the next
supercharger but it doesn't actually
really tell you how to drive here that
is through the steering wheel on this
little screen so you don't have to be
like looking at this gigantic screen
over here to see where you're supposed
to turn instead the turn-by-turn
directions are right here and when
you're driving it's exactly in your
field of view like I feel like this is
precisely where I want to be looking to
see the turn-by-turn direction so thumbs
up for that there's a bunch of other
stuff that you can do with the screen
but what I like is the rearview mirror
it doesn't give you a few huge field of
view here but it doesn't matter because
here there's a button for the camera so
you can hit a rearview camera and that
shows you what's behind the car and then
you can take these two windows and say
swap them so that your overview of your
trip is up here your rearview mirror is
here and you can even fullscreen this a
little bit more so it's as big as it can
possibly be and I like this set up for
driving okay let's take a look at the
car give this a little magic key fob
when you get close the car recognizes
you're coming by so it starts turning on
the mirror folds out you can press the
door and the door opens up automatically
which is super nice a thing that I
thought was a total gimmick but I love
it is when you get in the car when you
press the brake the side door closes
automatically this is a bulking
something-or-other one star do not
recommend this wire though connects back
to there's a little nice dash space
where you can plug in a traditional
cigarette lighter it also has two USB a
ports which is charging my laptop
actually from the battery of the car
and another wire which is going up to
the dash cam that I have set up so that
you can see what's going on on this
route trip from inside the car you can
actually control the doors as well so
you can say that you want a driver door
open and the passenger door open and
they'll just go alright let's get out to
watch the impressive thing that
everybody likes which is the amazing
Falcon wing doors on this thing
apparently in the settings they have
some auto hide features that will open
up higher or lower based on the space
that you're in the trunk of the car also
goes up these are all the wires and
adapters I was messing around with
before to actually charge the Tesla they
come in this nice little case obviously
on this road trip I'm not carrying
around one two three four five six seven
people so instead I have these seats go
flat there's a little button on the top
here you press when you press it the
head pops down you can then fold the
whole thing flat so it gives you just a
ton of space alright that's the trunk
let's go let's go around to the front we
can take a look at the engine inside
it's pretty awesome lol no engine of
course because this is a Tesla so we
don't need all disgusting fluidy engine
e stuff but like your grandpa knows how
to fix but you don't really care about
there's nothing in here the whole car is
really just the wheelbase the other
wheelbase and a big battery that
connects the two of them with some
electrical engines it's been both of the
wheels but everything above that is just
car so now with all that space you may
be asking yourself grey I haven't seen
any suitcases on this trip I haven't
seen any luggage you know the kind of
stuff that you'd need for a big old
roadtrip like this car is pretty empty
because there's no traditional car stuff
taking all the space there's space
everywhere including right here in the
back there's a panel that you can pull
up and here is where I've actually
hidden all of the stuff that I packed I
like it to look like I'm not carrying
all my possessions in the car
the only thing then are these cupholders
I don't know if it's the way I fit in a
car or what but this cup holder is
impossible for me to reach I have to
move my arm all the way back behind the
seat to then move it forward to be able
to get the drink and up like my elbow
naturally goes exactly where this cup
holder is there should be a cup holder
here where there should be a cup holder
here but this spot
that spot is is no bueno for a cup
holder
alright that's everything it's time to
pack it up and figure out what we're
doing
[Music]
yeah good dog okay I think I've been
sitting here long enough no I know
passed me said something like I cannot
leave Fox peak with less than a
completely full battery but you know
what I'm not obligated to that guy he's
not here right now
I've discovered something I don't need
to go to Eli I can go to a place called
Austin in the middle there's an RV park
in Austin that if I can get there they
have a 50 amp charger now hopefully I
have the right accessories to be able to
make that work but I have a 20% margin
of error to make it to Austin to be able
to charge and I'm in a dice rolling kind
of mood I didn't come across the goddamn
ocean to drive on a road I've already
driven or to set a gas station for
another three hours it's time to get out
of here and go get possibly stranded in
the desert what's the worst that can
happen well death death is always the
worst that can happen okay I actually
spent the next 15 minutes finding every
single setting in the settings panel
that I could flip to make energy savings
the maximum amount possible and get the
cabin pre cooled to save energy on air
conditioning as well so I didn't just
bolt out of here I spent a long time
being fussy about things but now it's
time to go all right we're on the road
there's a bunch of stuff that I can
possibly do to extend the range just a
little bit and so far so good we're up
1% I'm sure that'll read 100 by the time
we get there if trends continue so I'm
feeling pretty great here we are
together
the loneliest Road in America
[Music]
[Laughter]
about halfway to Austin which is about
halfway along my journey of this section
of the loneliest road we're estimating
at 16 percent upon arrival in Austin
which is pretty good
I think this was a good decision
I think we're gonna make it Bailey blue
who just popped up this alert she's
getting concerned that were too far from
all the super chargers and I don't blame
her we are smack dab in the middle of a
super charger desert don't worry you've
got me through those mountains I'll get
you through this desert of electricity
[Music]
you're officially reached Austin City
Limits and holy hell am i relieved
hello Austin community services boy am I
glad to see you now it's time to try and
find the Pony Express RV camp Pony
Express or is that down okay great thank
you very much man oh my god I'm so
excited to be here
goldmine and that is what I'm looking
for 50-amp deliciousness this is the
moment of truth really because if this
doesn't work I am kind of alright you
and you should go together
ooh that looks sketchy awesome okay
fantastic we've at least got electricity
we've got 40 amps now you guys the
question is to see if I can find a hotel
where I can stay and there's one
possibility here which is there's a
hotel up the road I've got some keys any
toasty warm room which I'm super happy
to have I am ridiculously unprepared for
this weather I thought I was driving
into the desert oh my god so warm
thank you heater
thank you door thank you desk
thank you microwave I'm so glad to be in
this room so I realized yesterday that I
had dramatically underestimated how much
storage space I was going to need
running all of these cameras and of
course right now I have files that exist
only on the dash cam cans and that's
just one copy and one copy is none copy
so I have to get two copies so we need
to copy into something else when I copy
to something else amusing no one cares
no one cares about your technical
problems
[Music]
yeah I need some coffee
hello
okay after a night on the charger all
sets go substitute coffee go they need
you great thank you town of Austin no
it's not that you lie supercharger
desert and there's more to go I normally
wear contacts when I'm driving but my
eyes are bothering me so I'm back to my
glasses but it is a driving into the Sun
morning so I'm gonna be pulling the
super cool look shades on top of
prescription glasses I have never been I
think on a longer more isolated Road
and this I was worried about taking the
Tesla where no Tesla is supposed to be
but this is a lifetime experience
first real coffee of the day acquired a
lovely little cafe in Eureka man I wish
I had more time to explore this town I'm
gonna be late enough from Moab as it is
so I got to get going and the danger of
stopping anywhere with a beautiful
Bailey blue Tesla is that everybody
wants to talk about it so expect Tesla
conversation related delays wherever you
go now we just need to find a place to
hook up and pay oh sweet man that never
gets old
okay the nice woman at the casino set me
up with a license to park and a place to
work in the hotel with Internet
Internet's are few and far between here
then I need to download some work files
if you listen to my podcast you'll know
that I like to use code names for my
projects this summer is ursus so there's
little statues calling to me if you're
ever on the loneliest Road come see the
bear the first great point and I wish I
had more time to explore the town
because it looks like there's a ton of
interesting stuff here but once again if
I'm gonna get to Moab on time I really
need to get going what's your name Oh
Tinker Bell this never gets old
as you press the button
the whole thing I'm listening to the
episode of cortex that we recorded back
at WWDC for any final changes that need
to be made and then if I ever have
internet again I will give the all okay
for it to be posted we made it to
Deseret
it didn't take long for Deseret to start
looking like Deseret we do drive in the
West make sure to get red tinted
sunglasses
it makes the whole experience better not
that this isn't beautiful but upping the
saturation sure doesn't hurt
coming up on the town of Delta what
should have the last RV park for the
loneliest Road section of this trip I
see RVs ahaha
man this is the nicest looking RV park
I've seen yet proper spaces grass let's
just see do they have us flip the switch
Green Green Green Green alright
fantastic family blue isn't the only one
that needs some power it's dinner time
it's an interesting thing has happened
now that I'm here there's a supercharger
up here in Afeni Utah that I've never
noticed before or I swear to God is
brand new it wasn't there when I was
looking at the roots a couple days ago
I was thinking I needed to go to a
supercharger down here which would have
been laying out of the way but this one
says I can make it there with eight
percent remaining given all of this it
means that since I have reached the edge
of the loneliest Road in America and I
am off the supercharger desert I can
make it to a supercharger and make it to
Moab tonight
every gamble on this trip so far has
worked out amazingly so I'm going to
roll the dice one last time
daylight's burning
they're all thank you antelope RV park
in Delta you are the reason I might make
it to Moab tonight alright I gotta put
down the camera we gotta go
Oh 28 miles to spare
looks like we're topping out at around
270 miles per hour that we sit at the
charger superchargers I feel like I
really appreciate you after the
loneliest road it was too easy at the
beginning but now I understand just how
great you are gonna be 50 minutes here
before we can move on to Green River I
gotta say I'm feeling pretty great just
to be back on the supercharger network I
feel like that's already quite an
accomplishment
I don't know maybe I'll charge up and
who would the truck train
okay the hell with it the sun's going
down but you know what I don't want to
be showing a bolete tomorrow
I'd rather get there tonight time for
Tesla after dark let's do this
[Music]
her bust
so I made a bad assumption that there
were going to be lights all over this
highway and there are not I think I
would have not done this if I had
realized it was going to be in total
darkness for a hundred miles
83 miles to go
holy am I glad to be off that
Highway alright I thought the most
stressful driving was gonna be that snow
but boy was I wrong I am I am literally
I am literally shaking just 20 minutes
to kill while she's charging okay I'm
full of I'm full of adrenaline and
nerves I'm just gonna walk around for a
minute and shake it off I guess this is
the eponymous Green River let's get back
inside here oh thank you John Wesley
Powell History Museum for installing his
Tesla Chargers all right just a tiny bit
longer until Moab and then we're done
for the night
nope I'm gonna stop it here I can't show
you anymore fast forwarded footage with
fun music underneath it this was a dumb
dangerous decision at the end of a long
series of dumb dangerous decisions I've
been driving since Austin I should have
stopped at the RV park I should have
stopped at the supercharger I definitely
should have stopped at Green River but I
didn't this is how catastrophic errors
happen and I just got really lucky I
will never do this again please go to
bed if you're driving nothing is that
important so I'm going to skip past all
this now
yeah yeah ah it's hard to get that spot
isn't it okay so while I was out here
Tesla literally announced the next
version of their autopilot system with a
ton of improvements including more
sensors on ramp off ramp ability better
ability to hold tight the lanes and take
turns and smart summon and a whole bunch
of other stuff this is one of the things
I love about technology because
technology involves the promise of
constant iteration and improvement and
it is the reason why I have just never
cared about cars at all but I've been
really interested in Tesla since I first
heard about them because it seems to me
much less a car than a computer on
wheels
[Music]
yeah
first
No
yeah
[Music]
the ceiling is really low I can't
actually can't actually stand up at that
place Oh God
oh yeah that's not that's not creepy at
all
oh god yeah
nope nope nope nope
watch the hell out for that makes it 10
times creepier is this certainly seemed
like a ghost town except there are a lot
of these pretty shiny new no trespassing
signs around there's post office which
is I'm gonna guess actually locked yeah
see so that's actually locked there's
this new looking sign smile you're on
camera the security camera that sure
looks like it's active Jesus Christ not
gonna lie I'm kind of terrified openness
this thing looks like a puzzle out of
Myst well I do actually have to go wait
don't drop your phone down the toilet
this time
and if you say so well time to go now I
think cars do feel a bit like a bubble
of security and safety that you can take
with you wherever you go
and I'm glad I came out to this ghost
town but the feeling like there are
people around is creepy as all hell so I
am very happy to head back to that
bubble of safety and security and get
back to Moab in the car
lock the doors
goodbye Cisco
I've been in Moab for a few days getting
work done getting podcast recording done
[Music]
all of my planning and preparing for the
final and hardest part of this summer
she's VidCon not looking forward to that
but also when I can taking advantage of
this unique and austerely beautiful part
of the country driving through the West
is like nothing else this trip we've
been just what I needed
driving with Bailey especially through
some unexpected difficulties I've gotten
over a lot of the fear and hesitation I
had about driving I'm really
appreciative for that this is my final
day in Moab it's when I take the time to
appreciate it too before I have to drive
to LA
got my coffee got my music now just four
stops left until I have to be in LA and
at VidCon but no need to do well
Moab I'll see you again soon Bailey
let's enjoy the last of the desert
driving this is the entrance to the San
Rafael swell all right Bailey I know
that our time together was growing short
but I'm glad that I get to take you
through one of my favorite sections of
Interstate let's do this girl
105 mile
[Music]
you
that is some serious solar paneling
it's factorio man I wanted that upgrade
it's time to be agriculturally inspected
this was the last charging pit stop for
Bailey not gonna lie I am I am getting
pretty emotional without saying goodbye
to this girl
I feel like we've been through a lot
together
you've had a fun romp through the
deserts I think we got it we've gotta
clean you back up before you go back to
your normal life the works of course
only the best for Bailey I know you
don't want a bath
you'll be happy to be cleaned and you
know you'll be you'll be glad to be back
home once you're there see doesn't that
feel good
look how good you look all right girl
let's get me to VidCon a new home
[Music]
rumors there Billy
you